Donald Trump's world is crumbling around him.
He doesn't understand anything.
He's furious all the time.
He doesn't understand how viruses work, how
vaccines work, how masks work, how Lysol and
bleach and isopropyl alcohol work.
And he spent his entire weekend tweeting everything
from re-tweeting, his own tweets to pushing
and on conspiracy theories to attacking Barack
Obama and the media.
At one point, listen to these numbers, Trump
sent 52 tweets and read tweets in an hour.
That is almost one tweet per minute.
Trump sent more than 50 tweets over the weekend
about the Russia investigation.
Trump sent over a hundred tweets in a single
day.
I am not going to subject you to all of these.
The content is mostly irrelevant for our understanding
of how hard this dude is failing.
But check out some of these are completely
out of control, man.
Without common sense or inhibitions.
Re-tweeting.
Endless conspiratorial attacks on Barack Obama
and the FBI for the Russia probe.
We have some of them on the screen.
The content is mostly irrelevant.
These are the rantings of a madman and that's
how they should be interpreted.
Continuing about one tweet per minute, sometimes
three or four or even five tweets in a single
minute.
Trump even retweeting his own tweets from
hours earlier.
We can't possibly go through hundreds of Donald
Trump's tweets.
Nor would it make sense to.
The content, again, is not really the focus
here.
But the gist of this so that you understand
the next wave of propaganda.
The gist of what we saw over the weekend is
that Donald Trump is now renewing his claim
and his focus on the entire Russia investigation
being a calculated illegal conspiracy involving
Barack Obama to end his presidency.
And unfortunately, and this is why, as I spoke
about in the last segment, I fear that Trump
is somehow going to figure out a way to get
himself reelected.
This could be the perfect distraction from
the fact that almost 81000 people as of this
morning have already died from Corona virus.
And that number continues to climb last week.
Donald Trump's Justice Department decided
they're not going to go forward with the prosecution
of Michael Flynn, Donald Trump's disgraced
former national security adviser.
Understand that Flynn pleaded guilty and the
Justice Department has decided in what is
one of the most overtly corrupt actions of
the Trump presidency.
Hey, we aren't going to move forward.
The case against him isn't that strong.
He pleaded guilty.
So now they're using this absolutely corrupt
decision by Trump's attorney general, William
Barr, to try to revitalize the case that the
entire Russia investigation was bogus, illegal.
It was Obama's illegal plan.
And on and on and on Fox News regularly over
the weekend using the term bombshell.
So we're going to talk about a bunch of different
things here.
Number one, I briefly on the Michael Flynn
thing.
If Donald Trump had pardoned Michael Flynn,
it would have been another one of these sick,
corrupt elements of a Donald Trump's cronyism
and nepotism and everything he said that he
would root out that he actually embodies.
But it would have been less concerning than
Trump's attorney general coming in and saying
about a case that was built up over years
where you achieved a guilty plea.
Yeah.
We're not going to prosecute that anymore.
That's a level of corruption involving the
Justice Department that is actually far scarier
than Trump simply pardoning his friend or
his guy.
And we'll have more time to talk about that.
A few other things that that we need to talk
about.
First of all, one hundred and twenty five
tweets in one day, 52 tweets in an hour.
People who work fast food.
People who teach school.
People who work in factories.
Me, everybody I know who has a job.
None of them have time to tweet 52 times in
an hour.
Even people whose job it is to tweet typically
don't tweet 52 times in an hour.
This is not normal behavior.
It has to be stopped.
And there's only one way to stop it.
And you know it and I know it.
And it's happening about five and a half months
from now.
Number two, the Republican Senate must be
punished for this in November.
I know that there's a lot of focus on Trump,
but if it weren't for the Republican Senate,
Trump would have already been removed or at
least could have been removed.
Remember that impeachment trial last week?
I got a call about, you know, what's more
important, the moving Trump or defeating Republican
senators in the fall.
You get to vote and vote.
You don't have to pick.
I'm voting in the presidential or I'm voting
in the Senate election.
It's an all of the above situation.
Republicans must be punished.
They aren't just complicit.
They're actively involved.
There's a whole bunch of Republican senators.
Martha McSally, Susan Collins, Cory Gardner.
You know, we've talked about the whole list
of them.
They could all be removed.
In addition to removing Donald Trump.
And then lastly, we're in the midst of a 100
year pandemic.
And Trump is failing in his handling of that
pandemic.
And he tweeted 100 more than 100 times in
one day if anyone did anything like this at
work.
If a firefighter was tweeting while a house
was burning down.
If an airline pilot was tweeting during an
emergency landing, anybody else would be fired
from this.
They would be removed from their job depending
on what the costs were of their distraction.
They would be criminally prosecuted.
And we need to make sure that Trump is held
accountable in the only possible way that
he's going to be held accountable.
I believe part of what might have set Trump
off this particular weekend is Barack Obama
lashing out at Trump about his handling of
Corona virus.
And that's what I want to talk about next.